[Applause]
[Music]
hi there visualpolitik fans a short time
ago here on this channel we published
our own rankings of some of the most
dangerous cities in the world deciding
the list is always complicated and it
forced us to choose between many
candidates that perhaps unfairly were
left out what can i say to be fair
mexico alone would have needed an entire
video north of its border there are also
many cities that deserve our attention
in the past video we mentioned st louis
a city we have already talked about here
on visualpolitik but we also could have
made room in the ranking for cities like
memphis detroit chicago or perhaps and
especially baltimore but of course how
could we dedicate just one minute to
baltimore when one of the best tv series
dedicated five full seasons to it of
course we're talking about the wire i'm
sure many of you have already seen it
and those of you who haven't check it
out because boy oh boy is it worth it
the thing is the last episode of that
series dates back to 2008 and since then
many things have happened so much that
they're launching an entire new
production
the wire creator returning to baltimore
for new hbo series we own this city as
is happening in the united states as a
whole violence has skyrocketed in
baltimore
[Music]
in 2021 alone 338 homicides were
recorded as a comparison in new york
there were 485 the difference is that in
new york there are 15 times more people
than in baltimore which has fewer than
600 000 inhabitants we're talking about
a city that in the 1950s numbered around
1 million inhabitants but of course
between those who die and those who
leave baltimore the city is losing
population worst of all the bad news
does not end there there are more and
more abandoned houses more drugs on the
streets and less future for its young
people so the question is are we talking
about the most decadent and violent city
in the united states what are the
baltimore authorities doing to change
the situation more importantly is it
having any effect today on visualpolitik
we're going gonna answer all of these
questions but first let's take a look at
some history
[Music]
the wire
[Music]
you looking to buy a house well you're
in luck with just two hundred thousand
dollars you can buy one in the heart of
baltimore but be careful because your
american dream could turn into a
nightmare at any moment the 19th century
brick townhouses that abound in the
western part of the city are now a
desolate site many are abandoned they
were once the dream home of thousands of
european immigrants who came to
baltimore during its rapid industrial
growth in the late 19th and early 20th
centuries it was a time when the largest
city in the state maryland became one of
the most prosperous places in the united
states thanks to its factories its steel
production and its port
[Music]
and so in 1950 baltimore was the sixth
largest city in the united states
however a third of its inhabitants
migrated as shipping and steel
industries closed baltimore's crisis
then worsened further in the 1970s and
80s when heroin cocaine and crack
cocaine began to circulate in abundance
on its streets in this way drug
addiction spread to the poorest
neighborhoods in the west side of the
city where radical laws and clearly
racist housing policies had concentrated
the african-american population which by
the way accounts for about two-thirds of
all current inhabitants
baltimore's decline over the last few
decades is evident despite having been
one of the great cities in the united
states and having such valuable assets
is the prestigious johns hopkins
university it's poor commerce in such
attractive areas as fell's point the
truth is that the problems continue to
multiply
[Music]
in the 1990s other major u.s cities such
as new york were successful in their
fight against crime thanks to a
combination of economic prosperity
reduced alcohol consumption and
increased police pressure meanwhile
baltimore sank lower and lower the
numbers speak for themselves and here
they indicate that one-eighth of
baltimore's population is addicted to
narcotics and the city has the highest
rate of venereal disease in the country
as well as one of the highest homicide
rates
to make matters worse since 1990
baltimore has lost more than 75 000
industrial jobs that have not been made
up for by other activities as a result a
significant portion of its residents
have been trapped in poverty in the most
depressed neighborhoods in this city
more than half of the adults are
unemployed and half of the adolescents
are regularly absent from school to give
you an idea a study conducted by
sociologists at john hopkins university
concluded that only four percent of
children from the most deprived areas of
baltimore managed to finish college only
four percent
[Music]
these are terrible figures that
represent an enormous blow to the social
programs promoted by the democratic
party and that in view of what these
numbers show have been a practically no
use democratic politicians have
controlled baltimore city hall since
1967. we're talking about 55 years of
government that have gone from failure
to failure in what was once known as
charm city
at the turn of the century for example
many hopes were pillared on the mayor
martin o'malley a young lawyer of irish
descent he promised to reduce inequality
and clean up the streets with a zero
tolerance policy he urged police to stop
young people acting suspiciously and
search them for weapons or drugs and of
course the police completely embraced
zero tolerance they targeted those who
met the two requirements being young and
being black a profile that as you can
imagine abounds in baltimore and guess
what it got out of hand
in 2005 alone baltimore police made 100
000 arrests remember they were talking
about a city of only 600 000 people as
this rate of arrest was completely
unsustainable o'malley had to backtrack
on this heavy-handed approach to
policing but the damage was done the
plan destroyed confidence in the police
throughout much of the city
the result was a perfect climate for
gangs violence and crime of all kinds so
those who've had the opportunity have
not hesitated they've got out of there
some 16 000 buildings are officially
designated as vacant but the real
numbers could be double that entire
streets of houses are boarded up in the
last six years alone 5 000 houses have
been demolished to make matters worse
the credibility of the local
institutions has also been shaken since
2010 two mayors have resigned after
being involved in corruption scandals to
give you an idea in the last 12 years
baltimore has had six different mayors
and as many political commissioners a
real disaster which of course has not
gone unnoticed notice what the president
himself said about the city in 2019
trump attacks another african-american
lawmaker and calls baltimore a
disgusting rat and rodent-infested mess
the worst part is that democratic
politicians had nothing to counter him
with baltimore has become the closest
thing to a drug supermarket that money
can buy and if things at the start of
the 21st century were already bad since
2015 they've gotten even worse check
this out
we own this city
you all know who george floyd is sadly
but you should know that before george
floyd there was freddie gray and so many
others who have been victims of what we
might call racial violence at the hand
of some police officers in the united
states the point is that in 2015 freddie
gray who was only 25 who'd been arrested
for carrying a knife died while in
baltimore police custody as a result of
an injury he sustained to his spine
while being transported in a police van
it was apparently standard practice for
baltimore police to handcuff arrestees
not protect them with seat belts and
drive roughly so they were as close to a
ball in the trunk as possible bumping up
against each other all over the place
the fact is that mass protests and riots
spread throughout the city it was
something like a point of no return as a
result of this event riots increased by
50
and now news stories like this are not
uncommon
baltimore tops 300 homicides for seventh
consecutive year now hold on a minute
baltimore is a city where every once in
a while a black man is killed by the
police but mostly it is a city where
virtually every day a young black man is
killed by another black man incidentally
many including a federal government
investigation blame the police
themselves for this
racial bias pervasive among baltimore
police doj says how is a police force
going to ensure security if no one
trusts it if the majority of the
inhabitants of a city see as a hostile
institution and refuse to collaborate
with them
this is a problem incidents of police
brutality make it much more unlikely
that the residents of black
neighborhoods will go to the police to
report crimes and cooperate with any
investigations and the same distrust
extends to judicial bodies which
logically are closely related to the
police themselves and that's not all to
top it all off some members of the
police force dedicated years to
extorting money from innocent people and
robbing drug traffickers to take their
business let's just say they thought
they were the lords of the city
some measures of justice baltimore city
pays 525 000 to victim who says corrupt
gttf cops wrongly sent into prison part
of 14 million dollars in settlements in
the end the economic crisis job losses
narcotics and political corruption
fueled the disaster but wait a minute
because there is still more
[Music]
today violence is fueled by an enemy
that goes beyond baltimore's borders we
are talking about fentanyl a highly
potent synthetic opioid that has largely
replaced heroin it's crazy in 2021 alone
more than 100 000 people 100 000 people
died in the united states from overdoses
the situation is so dire that in his
last state of the union address
president biden himself made this a
national priority first
beat the opioid
epidemic
there's so much
we can do
increased funding for prevention
treatment
harm reduction and recovery get rid of
outdated rules and stop doctors and the
stats stop doctors from prescribing
treatments
stop the flow of illicit drugs by
working with state and local law
enforcement to go after the traffickers
the fact is in 2007 opioid overdoses
claimed the lives of 256 baltimore
residents mostly from heroin in 2018
that number had more than tripled to 814
deaths from fentanyl baltimore has the
highest opioid death rate of any u.s
city and now it has a plan to reduce it
whether the plan is any good is another
matter check this out
[Music]
drugs and tax addicts
[Music]
baltimore mayor brandon scott of the
democratic party wants to address this
overdose boom by opening safe injection
sites these are places where people go
to consume narcotics they are there
under the supervision of medical
personnel who can intervene quickly in
case of overdose to prevent death
imagine how bad things must be for these
plans to be put on the table it's not an
original idea but is an idea that
recently ran into opposition from the
trump administration which struck down a
similar proposal by the city of
philadelphia in federal court the law is
currently enforced at the federal level
in the united states that open public
places for drug use are not allowed but
now all of that could change with biden
justice department signals it may allow
safe injection sites members of the
democratic party who defend these sites
argue that trying to save the lives of
these people comes before any other
consideration good intentions are not in
question here but is it really in the
best interest of addicts to open a place
where they can go into almost anything
it's a difficult question and a
controversial one to say the least and
it doesn't look like it can particularly
help improve things in baltimore
[Music]
speaking of the future take a look at
this news item study finds average
earning baltimore family earns 14.1 of
their annual income towards taxes this
means that in baltimore they pay 50 more
in local taxes than the average large
u.s city
the city has a tax regime with very
aggressive progressivity and overall the
city ranks fourth among the largest u.s
cities with the highest tax burden kind
of like the golden dream of many bernie
sanders wing democrats
this high tax burden has an explanation
as you have seen the city has been
losing population since 1950. so what
the democratic party politicians who
have run baltimore since 1967 done
nothing less than raise taxes to try to
maintain city revenues in the face of
taxpayer flight so in addition to the
generalized problem of violence
narcotics lack of job opportunities we
also have the highest taxes in the
country and the question is who in their
right mind is going to want to move to
baltimore what business or person could
survive in such circumstances what
person could thrive but of course high
taxes drive out more professionals and
reduce household income making it
difficult for businesses to grow this
reduces the supply of jobs and
aggravates the problems with violence
and narcotics it's something like a
destructive death spiral and yes i'm
sure some of you are thinking but grant
we've got to support public services and
you're right but you know what take a
look at this we have graduated
who can't read
flat out can't read
illiterate
getting a high school diploma i have
diploma in their hand
that they couldn't read that sounds like
an exaggeration
for hyperbole it's not some research
indicates that 77 of high school
students in baltimore have elementary
school reading ability and comprehension
it's a total disaster
[Music]
the question is who the hell's going to
want to move to baltimore visualpolitik
viewers this city needs to hit the reset
button and start from scratch it
wouldn't hurt to copy the economic
policies of states like texas or florida
along the way if things don't change
this once great city will end up as
rubble if one thing is clear is that the
democratic plan for baltimore has not
worked at all but seeing this it's over
to you now what solution would you
propose to fix the problems of this city
leave us your comments below and let's
get a debate started now if you found
this video interesting don't forget to
like and subscribe to all of us here at
visualpolitik all the best and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you